ugh of course this is mark hyman's
mantra
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by bill and i
will be reviewing another harper's
bazaar
what i eat in a day by teagan diet
creator and
best-selling author dr mark hyman
but before i get into it i want to chat
about my sponsor buildbar
so as you guys know i was never really
into the whole protein bar thing for a
really long time because i felt like
most of them
were basically just like less delicious
chocolate bars
and i would rather have a chocolate bar
than something that tasted like crap
even if it did have protein in it
but as a busy breastfeeding mama i'm
all about quick easy handheld snacks
so i was really surprised when i tried
one of these they literally taste
like a marshmallow coated in chocolate
so
good like i would eat these even if they
didn't have protein in them
so today we're gonna go for
peanut butter yeah because it's morning
so you got to get your
your peanut butter fix in this one's got
19 grams of protein
let's see gotta love peanut butter and
chocolate that is a classic
mmm
[Music]
[Music]
eat this then i'll get to the video
okay that is so good do i have chocolate
my face oh my god
but because it is a lower sugar bar i
probably pair this
like if it's for breakfast with some
fruit or toast
be great post-workout snack for muscle
repair but these have also been
awesome in the middle of the night as
breastfeeding fuel way
less obnoxious or crunchy or messy
compared to having like nuts
or dried cereal in bed anyway all the
flavors i've tried so far are super
yummy and i'm really excited to make my
way through the rest of this box
with you guys so if you want to try them
out i'm going to leave a link below
for 15 off of your order also super
quick before we dive in you can pause
the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating
i will be evaluating meals based on
their nutritional merit alone
which says very little about their
overall value so
if it's not supporting your food journey
by all means
sid this one out and of course don't
forget to subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on
a episode all right let's dive in
i lay in bed and i simmer i simmer in
that twilight between
waking and sleeping and i listen to what
it has to tell me
i listen to the dreams that i had i try
to go back and think about them and just
feel what i want
and then i meditate so that sounds like
a really great ritual in the morning you
know
meditation is an amazing way to kick off
your day
we have a lot of research to suggest
that meditation can help reduce stress
anxiety depression and pain while
improving
memory and task efficiency as well as
biomedical markers like
blood pressure so i love that he's
advocating
for that i first often have a green tea
i like the brown rice roasted green tea
sometimes i'll have a coffee if there's
an espresso machine in the house i'll
definitely have that with some
maybe macadamia milk awesome and i like
that he switches things up too you know
um ultimately nothing really to comment
on here because as you know
i don't pester people about their coffee
order
you drink it how you like it and that is
cool with me
caramel macchiato light ice not heavy if
it's heavy
i'm not going to drink it don't put a
little bit of soy in it not a lot
just nothing to taste and go oh boy i
will just say
that macadamia nut milk is one of the
more pricey options on the shelf today
but it definitely has been a trend to
watch over the past few years
now it's often selected over other nut
milks like almond milk
because the trees are watered by
rainfall instead of
mechanical irrigation so a lot of people
think it is a more sustainable
choice having said that like most nut
milks
macadamia nut milk is pretty low in
calories
and fat and protein so just something to
keep in mind
if adding nutrition to your coffee is a
priority for you
i really well understand that food is
medicine not because i learned in
medical school but because
food works to regulate every single
system in your body
your gut your immune system your detox
system
everything i hate this phrase
but i can totally see you know mark
reciting this mantra to himself
every day while drinking his green tea
you know
food is medicine food is medicine
honestly
i may be a dietitian and i am fully
aware and believe in the power of food
but
this was likely a misinterpretation of
the original quote
and one that is now used far too often
to sell wellness culture bs
well i want to make it clear that what
you eat absolutely
does play a very important role in your
health
equating food to medicine does
both of these commodities and injustice
we do not just eat
for nutrients and fuel we eat for
culture love
joy comfort tradition community religion
and so much more this reductionist view
of food
also puts an overwhelming onus on the
individual
to maintain their own health status
simply by consuming enough
super foods and avoiding all of the
demonized
junk the reality is that health is not
as simple as
what we eat we know that disease risk
and ultimately death is likely better
related to
genetics and socioeconomic status and
environment and stress and other factors
so this mantra aims to reduce disease
down to
a form of well-deserved punishment that
somebody acquires when they fail to eat
the
right food ugh
like would you tell a person with cancer
that they should just forgo
chemo and just eat more chia seeds and
then when they die from the suggestion
that it's their fault no
okay let's move on to
mark's medicine food goat way
which has a2 casein i'll use sometimes a
plant protein like a pea protein or hemp
protein
adaptogenic mushroom all that goes into
powder in my shake i put in green tea
powder and pomegranate powder which are
great for the microbiome i put in
probiotics
i put a little mct oil that's great for
my long bike rides and keeps me going
and i throw in some frozen fruit
yeah see what i mean like pack enough
superfood powders into your vitamix and
you've apparently got the elixir
to good health and long life and if i
don't maintain an extremely high dosage
of herbal remedies
i will get very depressed oh god
it's happening right now now obviously
i'm being a little sassy and
there's nothing wrong with mark's
breakfast if this
brings him energy and joy but let's very
quickly
break this concoction down for you
protein so
love that mark has some protein in there
his smoothie pick is either
a plant-based pea pumpkin seed or
hemp-based protein
or a goat-based whey which contains the
a2 protein
instead of the a1 protein what he means
by this
is that while most dairy contains a
mixture of
a1 and a2 beta casein protein
there are some goat and cow's milk
products on shelves today
that exclusively contain the a2 protein
this may benefit some folks who have a
hard time digesting traditional dairy
but for whom lactose isn't the actual
culprit
early research suggests that the a1
protein
may cause a lot of the common digestive
symptoms
that most people usually just attribute
to lactose
so when people switch to an a2 milk they
can enjoy dairy just fine
so i am glad that he's found a product
that works for him
now for fat mark claims that the mct
oil provides a more even metabolism
which is what i call [ __ ] because
that's not really a thing
you keep saying some that doesn't exist
and you got thing one and thing two
corroborating your story like it does
and you why are you lying there it's
both
what i think mark is meaning is that
mct is metabolized as fueled differently
in the body compared to other fats
and that is true mcts or medium chain
triglycerides
can enter the cells without being broken
down like other fatty acids
so that they can be used as an immediate
energy source
great as for everything else this guy is
putting in there
well we do have some fiber-rich fruit so
that's good
and then we've also got a bunch of
powders like antioxidant rich green tea
powder
probiotics and pomegranate powder which
he
says is good for the microbiome but the
research i found on this
simply suggests that in a petri dish
it may work as a prebiotic fiber which
helps to feed the bacteria in the gut
but so does just eating a variety of
produce and
having a general healthy fiber-rich diet
as for the adaptogenic mushrooms we do
have a
number of studies on the benefits of the
most
commonly used adaptogenic supplement
ashwagandha
for stress and anxiety but the research
for these other magical mushrooms that
he cited
is definitely less robust some test tube
research has found that reishi mushrooms
might help to boost our immune system
and animal studies have shown some
benefits for
blood sugar management in rats with type
2 diabetes
but again we don't have the same kind of
evidence
for human adults we also have
a large met analysis of five different
studies
which found that it didn't have any kind
of beneficial impact
on cholesterol as a lot of mushroom
enthusiasts often suggest
does this mean that these powders are
useless
no not necessarily but in my
professional
opinion we don't have any strong
evidence to
justify the cost or the taste
ugh i actually tried some mushroom
coffee in my video right here
and it literally ruined my whole day
so yeah probably not a smoothie recipe
that i would try just saying because i
don't really snack because i just eat
good food and i eat plenty of food and
if i do snack i might have some
macadamia nuts or i might have some
almonds or i might have piece of fruit
[Music]
again with demoralizing language but
you could just say i don't eat between
meals because my meals are
large and satiating that would also work
though i don't know about you but i
probably wouldn't call
mark's smoothie breakfast super large
and satiating
no amount of superfood powders is going
to make up for the fact that it's still
probably like a 300 calorie breakfast
and that might just not be enough for a
lot of adults who are going on
crazy long bike rides so i would
absolutely
suggest maybe some nuts or fruit as a
snack
snack doesn't have to be a bad word it's
literally an important way to make sure
that you're getting all the necessary
nutrients
that your body needs in a day it's not
something that we need to demonize
i get that this is kind of mark's shtick
like
his social media and website is also
riddled with moralizing
dichotomizing and fear-mongering
language about food health and disease
this reductionist approach to wellness
clearly appeals to
a lot of people out there but obviously
is not for me let's see what he's having
for lunch
at the most amazing salad i had
sunflower sprouts
arugula from the farm cherry tomatoes i
put in toasted pumpkin seeds
watermelon radishes and some regular
radishes extra virgin olive oil which
has olio canthals all those great
medicines i put in balsamic vinegar salt
and pepper and some smoked salmon it was
wild coho salmon a little can of
mackerel
okay so this fat salad does
sound divine and i imagine it is
probably pretty
satiating as well so we've got loads of
healthy fats and protein in the fatty
fish and seeds
and lots of fiber-rich veggies but
considering
what a modest breakfast he had and that
he suggested he rarely snacks between
meals
i would say he could definitely stand to
maybe add a little carb in the mix i
know he is
pegan aka paleo vegan which i'll speak
more about
in a hot minute but maybe some like
roasted sweet potato
or another starchy carb would bulk this
up really nicely
and then for dinner i love to make a
rainbow assortment of colorful fruits
and vegetables nuts and seeds and
good quality protein so i eat really
delicious food there's no
depravation or starvation what i call
the pagan diet which is basically the
topic of my new book
okay so now let's talk about this whole
vegan diet thing now the paleo vegan
diet is exactly what it sounds like
the not so loving love child of the
paleo
and vegan diet most of you know that a
vegan diet or a plant-based diet
avoids all animals and animal byproducts
while a paleo diet
tries to mimic the diet of our hunter
and gatherer ancestors
focusing mainly on lean meats fish
fruits veggies nuts and seeds
in mark hyman's pegan version because
this is literally a made up diet
he suggests a diet rich in low glycemic
index organic veggies and fruit
nuts and seeds and omega-3 rich
low mercury fish the diet suggests that
you avoid any refined oils
food additives sugar gluten dairy and
significantly limit
your whole grains legumes and grass-fed
sustainably raised meat
in other words it's really [ __ ]
restrictive
the paleo diet in my opinion is kind of
bs
i mean i'm not sure why we would want to
emulate the life of our ancestors
when they literally live to an average
of 35 years old what a load of bugs my
father ate it every day of his life he
lived in a ripe old age of 38.
i mean i would almost be dead right now
and this smart guy
would be toast but even if we did
there's plenty of anthropological data
out there to suggest that our ancestors
actually ate a lot of grains and carbs
our bodies have also evolved to thrive
on modern food for example by producing
lactase enzyme to help us effectively
digest
milk and there's a lot of benefits to
modern day food processing
it's allowed us to i don't know not get
sick from raw eggs or meat
and to cook vegetables to make them
easier to digest
now plant-based eating and contrast does
have some more robust
research to back it up and what i think
we can maybe take away that's
positive from a diet pattern like
paganism is that it relies
less on ultra processed foods that are
higher in saturated fat
and it focuses more on whole foods rich
in
unsaturated fats and fiber but there are
a lot of restrictions to try to manage
here without driving yourself
absolutely mad so for example when
you're eating plant-based for
ethical or religious reasons for example
there's still a lot of room for fun
foods in your life
so we have coconut ice cream and vegan
burgers and
even just like a damn piece of toast for
heaven's sake but
mark's diet feels so righteous
and restrictive like it reads to me
like orthorexia 101 and i'm not
diagnosing
him with anything but that is my major
concern with a
diet pattern like this like there's not
a sprinkle of sugar
or convenient grocery store shortcut in
sight
not only does this feel more grounded in
morality than
actual wellness but it's also
reading as super elitist and exclusive
remember my review on sorella moore yeah
like i'm starting to wonder if this is
where she got her diet tips from
moving on mahi mahi ghee and jicama
a watermelon radish salad incredible
dressing which has tahini and lemon
juice
olive oil little cumin these little new
potatoes those lines made mushrooms
assortment of greens in the fridge
chard and kale and i stir-fried it with
a ginger it basically had four or five
different
dishes all vegetables plus a little bit
of protein okay so this
does sound pretty incredible uh we got
some
carbs and the potatoes we've got healthy
fats in the tahini
and olive oil we got protein in the fish
and we've got
lots of veggies in the salad and
mushrooms
as for said mushrooms mark suggests that
he eats them because they are
great for your brain and he's not
necessarily wrong
but we also don't have super strong
evidence of that
the research that we have licking lion's
mane mushrooms to alzheimer's
improvements
has been done on mice not humans and
the one small human study i was able to
locate
was done with lion's mane supplements
not the whole food the good news was
that taking these supplements for four
months
did improve mental functioning the bad
news was
that these benefits totally disappeared
when the supplementation
stopped we also don't know what the
impact would be
of just like throwing a little mushrooms
in with your lunch
having said that research on the mind
diet has linked fruits and veggies to
better brain health so
generally speaking yes this dietary
pattern right here
is associated with good brain health
occasionally you know i might drink a
little tequila but maybe once a week
i mean i can't fault the guy on a shot
of liquor per week but honestly
this is why these stupid diet rules make
no sense tequila is often suggested as a
paleo-friendly drink because it's not
made from grains like gin
vodka or whiskey are but when you really
boil it down
liquor is liquor is liquor doesn't it
sound kind of stupid to you
that you've got the wellness guru's
blessing to do body shots at the bar
but your chastised for a smear of
natural peanut butter on your whole
grain bread
i'm not calling anyone out on their love
a well-made margarita
but let's get our nutrition priorities
straight here folks
i don't know about you but i smell some
major bulk here i
don't eat certain ingredients for
example i don't eat anything that's not
food if it has
weird ingredients weird chemicals in it
if it's not actually
something that nature made i won't eat
it got it
okay but i've got some questions here
for my
friend mark did nature make the green
tea powder
what about the adaptogenic mushrooms
powder or the refined
pea protein powder or the isolated
mct oil because i'm pretty sure
they didn't come out of the ground that
way i'm pretty sure our ancestors
didn't have that stuff oh and what about
the tequila
mark you do know that alcohol is
classified as a group one carcinogen and
is broken down
into a known toxin acetaldehyde
right i am so
over this elitist anti-chemical wellness
discourse
chemicals are in everything and natural
is not always
better as an example like here's a fun
little factoid to bust out at your next
zoom dinner party
we have artificial flavors like vanilla
that are made in a lab
and while they're deemed safe by the fda
they are
man-made chemicals synthesized in a lab
meanwhile natural vanilla extract can
not only
come from the vanilla bean but also from
get ready for this folks beaver's anal
glands
what yup yup yup
so you tell me which one sounds more
like
food to you we can communicate our food
preferences without moralizing
others and suggesting that certain foods
are poison
or toxic or just downright and edible
because they've been processed in some
sort of way
oh okay buy you comfort food what would
i eat
once in a while i love pasta so i might
have you know lentil pasta chickpea
pasta maybe soba noodles buckwheat
noodles
and i'll make a little pasta dish which
i really love okay so i am a huge fan
of bean based pastas because it's a
great source of protein and fiber
and is appropriate for those who may
need to eat a gluten-free diet
but based on his own arbitrary pegan
rules
this comfort food would be a major no-no
the ingredients in banza for example are
chickpeas pea protein tapioca starch and
xanthan gum last time i checked all of
those things are discouraged when you
eat
pegan i mean xanthan gum specifically i
would think mark would call out as some
sort of new age
poison because it is derived from sugar
and a lot of these gums and emulsifiers
often get demonized in wellness circles
for
their alleged role in poor digestion and
weight gain i've actually got a whole
blog post
outlining the faulty mice research that
this assertion is based on
but just know that normal amounts of a
lot of these additives
are completely safe and only shown to
cause digestive issues
in super large amounts definitely not
something to even think about
in the context of a bowl of chickpea
pasta the reason i'm even bringing this
up is to poke holes in mark's [ __ ]
diet that he's trying to market
and profit off of in this interview so
what can we say about dr mark's diet
it's
obviously quite nutrient dense i cannot
deny him that
there's very little i would even be able
to critique other than the fact
that it just doesn't seem like a whole
lot of food and it's not really a lot of
carbs either
i mean we got a protein smoothie for
breakfast a fat salad for
lunch and no snacks before dinner
just doesn't leave us with like a whole
lot of calories to work with
even if i'm being super generous on some
of the oil portions that he's adding to
foods
we're still looking at like 1600 to 1700
calories
and less than 100 grams of carbs
obviously it's not
keto but it's still not really that much
so i would definitely be down to see
some more carbs
sprinkled throughout the day even if we
were limited to just those grain-free
paleo-approved ones like sweet potatoes
and yeah the guy can totally use a snack
in there too
my bigger issue with this interview is
not surprisingly all that moralizing
language
when we put so much emphasis on eating
only
good food reducing food down to
medicine or tying our identity
so intimately to what we eat we miss out
on a lot of the sensual aspects of food
that make it a satisfying part of our
life
we make it so that if you slip up and
god forbid eat something that cavemen
didn't have access to
we become lazy and adequate
and lacking in self-control so i don't
care if the pagan diet
is rich in antioxidants and fiber and
low in additives and saturated fat
when it consumes so much of your life
and sense of self to maintain it
it cannot be a healthy way to eat
please know that we have come so far in
safe food production
not to mention lifespan since our
paleolithic ancestors roam the earth
and it is okay to eat a cup of chickpeas
a slice of bread or a cup of yogurt
because of it
not everything natural is superior to
things that are man-made
and not everything processed is
inherently toxic or unsafe
friends repeat after me everything
can be consumed in moderation and
nutrition
doesn't need to be black and white and
on that note that is all that i have for
you guys today
thank you again to bill barr for
sponsoring this video if you liked it
don't forget to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here
you